yes for about 50 years as I've worked at
these problems interpreting 18th century
history and other parts of American
history and broadening out now into
broader areas of Atlantic history in
general which we've been working on
Harvard where did you get started in
history well in the Harvard Graduate
School after world war ii and i was
discharged from the army I entered the
Graduate School and started working the
PhD and I've remained there ever since
can you remember what specifically
interested in you about history well all
of it really the stories of it the
importance of it a way of interpreting
what's happened to us and to the world
and the craft of it history in the
writing of history is a craft and the
craft of writing history it's not a
science sometimes it's an art but it's
always a craft and the craft of it of
how history is put together the way we
reconstruct from small pieces of
evidence of one kind of another and
illuminate dark parts that hadn't been
seen before that craft of history
interested me and still does enormously
take the revolution if you're a person
that's never read much about the
revolution or you're a young person
that's just starting out what would you
recommend they do to start well it
depends on what level well I bet to buy
it at the beginning in other words how
do you begin to learn in your opinion
correctly about the revolution in this
country well you should have in the
first place an outline of events to
begin with so you know approximately
what happened in in large terms and then
you go into some of the more critical
writings on it that get to the heart of
the issues and there are certain books
all along the way which seem to me to
come very close to the great issues
involved in the revolution but I think
you have to have some kind of a general
background of the structure of the story
the chronology of it to begin with
in order to make sense of any of the
details that follow but I think a
general outline
is necessary and then to be able to pick
the issues that are critical for
understanding what really happened is
there a person from revolutionary days
that you think it's the most important
well I think there there's a whole group
of them and I've written about them in
various ways who are critical it seems
to be to understanding what what
happened but there are shared qualities
among this group and when I tried to
write about the ideology of the
revolution it was really trying to put
together what was in the minds of the
leaders of the whole revolutionary
movement to see what they shared and to
see what the motivation was that could
be seen in what they wrote and what they
did it seems to me you can pick out
certain people who are obviously
critical in the whole process but
there's also a group phenomenon and
general issues and problems that are
involved and I've tried to write about
them in different ways in this current
book he's one of them in this book one
person that pops out right away it's
Thomas Jefferson well Jefferson of
course is one of the most complicated
people of the entire era and I wrote
this this piece in an effort he's come
under so much abuse recently the
criticisms just pile up and I've
enumerated them there but my aim in that
essay was to understand why this
happened why his reputation is what it
is and what he did and what he didn't do
and I find him a very complex man in
ways I tried to explain and Jefferson is
it's not easy to explain Jefferson but
he certainly had two dominant
characteristics that seemed to me to
have created the problems of his life
the first place he really was an
ideologue that is he believed in in
principles that he derived as a young
man about a kind of enlightenment
situation of reform and betterment that
could be achieved and this was high
ideals it was really ideological
he never relented in following those
principles but at the same time he was a
tough politician he was a good
administrator he knew what the world was
all about and the problems of his career
seemed to me to be the way in which
those two worked together and didn't
work together and he kept qualifying all
the way through his life he kept
qualifying the principles in order to
accomplish something in a very real and
practical way so that it's full of
contradictions that's why the essays
called ambiguities there are ambiguities
all the way through his career and it is
fascinating to see the way he clings to
the principles of his early commitments
and then qualifies them in practical
terms as he goes through difficult
problems of politics of economics
international relations and all of those
grand affairs of practical affairs which
as an administrator as president as
Secretary of State and just as a manager
of plantations he sees he has to do and
the problems of his career and the
complications of his reputation come
from his effort to do both they need to
maintain those principles at the same
time as dealing with the real problems
of politics of the act of the economy
and of international relations you say
that he wrote 19,000 letters well they
found that many of the people doing the
Jefferson Papers in Princeton have
identified at least 90,000 he was
extremely diligent and as I think I said
in there he was incapable of boredom he
did the most difficult kinds of thing
like treatises on the whale fishery at
the same time as he was dealing with
problems of high political theory of
economic theory of plantation management
his capacity was extraordinary and his
diligence was extraordinary but he's
caught up in the ambiguities between the
real practical world and those ideals
have you started with there never gave
up I wrote this down that you said in
your book his
loathing of slavery was sincere yes I
think it was how do you explain then
what he did with his own slaves well no
matter what he did with his own slaves
the that is a question but the real
question is what did he do about slavery
as such and the answer is he had no
solution to this problem his
condemnation of it goes all the way
through his career and it is involved
with racist views there's no question of
this which he shared with most of his
compatriots and the plantation world but
the interesting thing about this in a
way is that he felt it as he grew older
in the 1820s he came to see that he may
have been wrong about some of those
racist views though he never fully
changed
he had no solution to this problem as he
said and I quote this sometime this has
got to go from the face of the earth
it's an abomination and he knew it and
yet he he lived in that that was his
world and he had no solution to it at
one point he tried to confine it and his
contribution to the Northwest Ordinance
for example in a memo I think it was in
1784 which set up the north of the Ohio
States and with those states a abolition
of slavery was already an indication of
his views on this but it was easy
relatively speaking the hard thing was
what to do with the existing
institutions and he had no solution to
this the the numbers of the ages of
these folks that you learn about there's
one point you talk about it in year 1776
that Thomas Jefferson was 33 and that
James Madison was 25 and that Alexander
Hamilton was 21 yes any could that
happen today could people that age today
get this kind of well in the 18th
century of course 33 was a fairly
advanced age but what struck me about
that is that though the age differences
are not that great in fact Jefferson was
of an older generation
he had already by the
time he was involved in Affairs in 1776
he was already a very experienced
parliamentarian he had involved in major
drafting of major documents in Virginia
and the others were just emerging
Hamilton was still in college at the
time and Madison had just recently got
out and they're of a different
generation and they thought differently
the thinking of the three of them and I
tried to work that out in the book the
thinking of them is really quite
different Madison shared a great deal
with Jefferson there were collaborators
but they thought differently and
Madison's mind was different from how do
they think differently well Jefferson
thought in very large terms about public
affairs and he tried to as I said before
he tries to adjust those large thoughts
to the practicalities of life but he had
a lyric quality in his writing he wrote
some of his documents are superb in the
cadences and the way the words are put
together and the way that but they swing
there their lyric and madison had none
of that it's not easy to read medicine
it's easy to read Jefferson he was it's
such a lyric kind of prose but Madison
had a tight grained mind and he wrote in
very tight prose and I found in reading
some of Madison's writings that I have
to read it two or three times to really
get the meaning of it because it's so
compressed and he was also I have to be
said more original than Jefferson he saw
problems that Jefferson didn't see and
he explained things to Jefferson
especially in a very famous letter that
he wrote explaining the Constitution
when Jefferson was in Paris he explained
the Constitution to him and there are
problems involved in that he saw that
Jefferson never grasped Madison had a
tightly drawn mind original and seeing
difficult interior problems to what was
happening in politics as for Hamilton he
was much younger and he
saw a different kind of commercial
economic world opening up the Jefferson
didn't see but adjusted to gradually
Jefferson was still back in an agrarian
ideal state and Jefferson Hamilton was
moving out more and more into a more
modernizing commercial world that I
don't think fully Jefferson never
grasped though he did tried to adjust to
it you you spent how many years at
Harvard well all in all about 50 since
since I was a graduate student 19 well I
I got out of the army this was 1946 the
fall of 46 I entered graduate school and
have remained there where did you grow
up in Hartford Connecticut and what kind
of a family well parents do illiterate
my father's dentist not academics and
went to Williams College and then to
Harvard and why did you stay at Harvard
after you what you get your PhD there
too yes why did you stay there well
where was I supposed to go did you
always know you wanted to be a teacher
yes and and the historian the only
opportunity or the only invitation I had
to go elsewhere was when I was invited
to the Institute for Advanced Study in
Princeton but which is a marvelous place
but I didn't want to give up teaching
because of the professors at the
Institute don't formally teach and the
teaching that I was doing at Harvard
been a lot to me both the undergraduate
and graduate teaching and I didn't want
to give that up are you still teaching
well I'm not in client regular classroom
work but I'm running an international
seminar on Atlantic history which brings
in people young historians from all of
the areas surrounding the Atlantic Basin
Western Europe West Africa Latin America
North America coming together in groups
to discuss
the interactive history of the Atlantic
region and I run that seminar every
summer and we have workshops through the
year on more specific topics and the
idea is to bring young historians from
all over the Atlantic area together and
have them discuss work in progress on
big issues of the common history of the
Atlantic world such as migration the
governance cultural encounters and so
forth over these years all these 50 some
years that you've been in this business
what's in your opinions happen to
American interest in history well I
think it's it's gone up and down and
taken various phases and it's going
through different kinds of permutations
one of the interesting things of course
is currently how much interest there is
in the 18th century and not only
biographies but other kinds of histories
of the 18th century and it raises an
interesting question of why that's so
why why are Americans so fascinated by
the 18th century how close are we to the
18th century and it seems to me we are
closed in a way that other nations
aren't too
that far back in their past in what way
well we find a kind of relevance to
these issues that were at the heart of
the founding of the nation in ways that
I don't think you'll find easy parallels
to you might find a similar kind of
thing in some kinds of Irish history
where they're still struggling over the
issues of the 17th and 18th centuries
the relation of the Irish to the English
but with us there is a kind of relevance
to it that I think is quite unique and
that's the reason why in this book I
traced out the references of the Supreme
Court to the Federalist Papers because
the Federalist Papers and I find this
just a fascinating story that's why I
wrote that piece the fascinating thing
about the Federalist Papers it's
unlikely that they would ever have been
remembered in this way and have seemed
to so many people to be important the
Federalist Papers first of all while we
think of them as a great treatise of
political theory in fact the Federalist
Papers were strong together frantically
in a political battle over ratification
in New York that lasted from October
until October 1787 until June or so 1788
and they were simply thrown together
some of the papers are drawn from other
things the three people actually to
Madison and Hamilton had written and
they're put together frantically to meet
printers deadlines and furthermore their
world was totally different from ours in
social terms of economic terms the
interesting thing is that the Federalist
Papers are considered to be relevant to
us that is they say something to us and
that essay is an effort to explain why
and as I say the appendix to the essay
is to track through the use of the
Federalist Papers by the Supreme Court
which I find extremely interesting I was
looking for then the number do you
remember the exact number well you know
the I don't remember the exact 200 yeah
but in the 18th century and early 19th
century was understood that the
Federalist Papers were really political
polemics
everybody knew that they're a part of a
big argument about the ratification of
the Constitution and there are
relatively few citations it grows
through the later 19th century and then
in the early 20th century it starts to
balloon in the latter the second half of
the 20th century there are a remarkable
number of citations the point is that
its authority as a comment on the
Constitution has grown with the distance
from the event and I find that very
interesting and that essay is an attempt
to suggest some of the reasons why
that's so and what you're talking about
is the citations and the decisions by
the Supreme Court the number of times a
reference to Federalist Papers yes
let's go over the basics on the
federalist papers how many were there
eighty-five
what were they written for well they
were written for the Federalists to get
New York to ratify the Constitution this
was part of the great gratification
debate and it started with three people
John J who dropped out after five papers
by him and then I think 29 by by Madison
all the rest by Hamilton 51 by blank by
Hamilton one thing he point out is that
the first 36 were written by Alexander
Hamilton yes he started he really was
managing this and in fact he started it
and he managed most of it and as I say
the large majority of the papers are his
not all the most important ones but he
wrote the large number today if
something like this were to happen and
what would we see these like op-ed
pieces in one of the papers yes it would
be something of that kind but the
Federalist Papers are part of a group of
these polemics that are going on through
this period I counted 24 series like
this of which this is the longest and of
course the most important but some of
the others were very important too and
the most important on the other side we
don't know who wrote it it's by
so-called Brutus but that's a extremely
interesting series of papers against the
ratification of the Constitution as it
was written
and so the Federalist Papers are part of
a polemic it's a political argument to
convince the ratifying convention in New
York to ratify the Constitution and in
fact the ratification in New York came
only at the end of the whole process
after nine states had already ratified
it was a terrible fight in New York and
that's why it was carried on this way
and as I said before these these people
Madison and Hamilton were turning out
these papers to a week then for a week
and meeting printers deadlines and the
to me radical thing about it is that
they are now seen when grouped together
as a comprehensive commentary
of almost theoretical nature about not
only American politics but about
politics in general and about freedom
and power but in fact they were thrown
together in this way at a time that was
very distant from ours and very
different from ours his problems why do
you think of the 24 different sets of
these kind of things that people
different people were writing why did
the Federalist Papers survive so
powerfully there better I mean they're
just more they're more comprehensive
they're full of details that the others
don't have and they're written by people
who were seeing a large picture and
trying to put the whole thing together
in their very hurried way and they're
just better in the intellectual content
of them than others there are others
that are interesting too and there is
now in Madison Wisconsin at the
University of Wisconsin project to
publish all of the documents related to
the ratification process and there is an
extraordinary number of such documents I
think they've got out something like 20
volumes already the Federalist Papers
are in the in the center of that huge
effort and I don't know quite what to
compare that outpouring of political
thought in the year between September
1787 when the Constitution was published
first and the ratification the final
ratification of nine states which i
think was in june 88
and during that time there is this huge
outpouring it's a population I estimate
at about a million voting members in the
whole in all of the states that's a very
small number the participation in small
places and newspapers in letters in
books in all sorts of expressions the is
it's just remarkable and the core of it
as we now think of it because of the
quality intellectually and its
comprehensiveness on the federalist side
are those papers turned out by Jay
Hamilton you say that Alexander Hamilton
wrote the first number onboard a river
sloop traveling from Albany to Manhattan
did yes that the whole thing was put
together frantically and he set this on
foot and then he wrote this in that
strange conditions and all the way
through they were writing it in strange
conditions he was carrying on his law
practice which was very profitable
Madison was at Congress most of the time
involved in many things and somehow they
put all this together so go back to the
revolution again something you spent a
lot of years on what were the people
that were leading the revolution wanting
what are they fighting for why did they
want the revolution well the the issue
really was power that is they were they
were faced with the problems of a kind
of power exerted against them which they
took to be a violation of the liberties
they had enjoyed his British subjects
and they thought that there was a turn
which they could interpret by the
history they knew and the what they knew
of the contemporary world there was a
turn towards tyranny as they saw it by
the exertion of central power against
the liberties they had enjoyed and they
were attempting to retain those
liberties against whatever force was put
over them and then it expands that they
have to justify it they have to
understand why they're doing this and
that leads to this whole expansion of
their ideological commitments as they
grope to explain what it is they're
trying to preserve and what it is
they're trying to oppose so that by the
time you get to 1776 there's an
elaborate structure of thought that's
worked out that justifies this and that
really sets American constitutional
thought on its path in one of your books
and I've got a bunch here I remember you
writing that that this was not this was
a prosperous place during the revolution
I mean we weren't this was the country
wasn't broke who what didn't live in
poverty and so it wasn't as if they
revolt they would
for a better life well I think that's
right I mean there are plenty of
problems but after the depression that
followed the Seven Years War so that's
in the early 1760 to the mid 70s 60s
where there was a depression what was
that about by the way before you go on
well after the Seven Years War which
ends formally in 1763 there's a
contraction of the whole military
operation that they had participated in
and the subsidies from the British
government that came in to support the
war against France and that intended a
wartime prosperity which collapsed after
basically after 1761 there was a period
of readjustment that was difficult those
were difficult times but by 1770 it had
come around in different ways and wasn't
the same acute economic problem so that
by the time you get to 1773 74 it's not
so much an economic squeeze that can
explain the events of those years which
start really at the end of 1773
on the picture I mean the cover of your
book you have the famous
portrait of a man they cut his head off
what's there what's the purpose here Ben
Franklin it is Franklin of course it's
the Martin portrait in London in 1766
and the the reason it was cut off was it
it was an attempt to show that this is
not a person so much as as a general
it's rethinking of the big problems of
public life and you see there Franklin
leafing through papers that are
presumably of some importance in public
life nose-to-nose with Newton I mean the
the statue that he's facing is Newton I
don't know if you can see it again on
the cover the interior picture it's in
in the middle of the book shows it
better but the reason it's cut off is
too impersonal eyes it that is to show
that you're really dealing with a
general issue rather than a single
individual thoughtful as Franklin is
there you see it better because there
you can see Franklin knows
to nose with Newton as he thinks through
presumably these problems of public life
that he was so involved in now you have
I think five chapters in this book all
lectures at one point yes they they were
all written as essays and and all given
as lectures in a somewhat different form
now Jonathan Yardley says this is your
valedictory effort this is your last
book is that possible I don't think so
at least I hope not
I wonder him what you would think when
you read that I I hope not but at the
moment I'm involved a number of things
which I hope will be survived these
years in the book you have a lot of
photographs of portraits and all yeah
it's gonna hold a bunch of them up and
let you tell us what they're about
what's what is this this series well
that series is on Franklin and that
essay is on American foreign policy as
in its most effective form it is a
combination of realism and idealism and
it's an essay that takes off from
comments by Felix Gilbert
who was a German refugee scholar in this
country whose background was in Prussia
and a Renaissance Italy the subject of
his studies he came to America and
published a book in seventeen in 1962
called to the farewell address in which
he argued that the uniqueness of
American foreign policy is its
combination when it's effective of hard
realism and idealism and I illustrate
that I think he was certainly right
about that and it's illustrated in the
career of Franklin in Paris in those
years ten years after 1776 when he
arrived in Paris and negotiated the
treaties with the French which really
determined the outcome of the revolution
he was keenly aware of his appearance
and his image and he used it in the
portraiture that was
and there's a enormous list of and I
have many of them in there of the
portraits of Franklin and they say
something beyond mere pictures of his
face where is this portrait and that was
the caution portrait which was done just
after he got to France in early 1777 and
was an ideological statement if there
ever was one
and it circulated wildly in many
different forms and became a statement
of American innocence its naturalness
and its capacity to reform in a way that
carried those ideas out as nothing else
could have done and Franklin was keenly
aware of this and he promoted these
kinds of what you might call
iconographic views of himself in many
different forms encouraged them and it
ends with his very great portrait by du
play C in 1778 which I have in color in
the inset there which is the last
portrait of him and which he understood
correctly was the most profound
visualization of him that could be made
you have this small picture in air of or
so well that's because when making that
medallion which was very popular and
which he circulated through Europe
the person who made it had no idea how
to capture that Ferhat and so he simply
took the hat off that popular portrait
of Rousseau and carried it over into the
medallion for Franklin since he had no
idea how how to draw in the medallion
form that original fur hat that Marten
fur hat did Rousseau and and Franklin
know each other
no I don't there's no there's no
significance in that what's the
significance of this well that is a
statuary form that shows louis xvi
giving documents to franklin they're
receiving they're received he's passing
over
the exact duck Youmans the Constitution
let me just I'll drop it down yeah and
read it what yeah see if I can find the
figure it says Franklin two Scrolls one
inscribed independence of America on the
other Liberty a dis mares their mayor
this man's yeah Liberty of the Seas yeah
which was a part of the reform in
international relations that Franklin
promoted and it was a sign of friendship
between France and America in these
critical years the other 2015 there the
how this is a state yeah yeah that is a
little it came in a glass case and it
shows the experimenter the scientist at
work and the Hat comes off and the hair
was very real and the little machine
would would work and this was popular it
was circulated there were a few copies
of it around which I think again the
idealization of Franklin is the great
scientist and experimenter meant
something ideologically in one of your
footnotes you refer to the fact that
Benjamin Franklin when he went to I
think it was Paris had a copy of what
are the original eighty-one of the early
drafts had 80 copies of the Articles of
Confederation he did I mean it just rang
like today when there was a leak of the
document coming out and how much did
that went on back in those day well
there was a lot of and that enters into
this Franklin story a great deal that
was he took with him to Europe when he
went in 1776 an early draft of the
Articles of Confederation it was not
what was finally accepted and there are
significant differences but he was so
eager to promote the constitutional
forms that have been worked out in
America that he took it and had it
published as he did many other documents
from the states had it published and
translated and it was in that form
actually that it reached an English
audience through the translation of this
draft form that went into French first
and it was typical I have a good deal of
this in the book
it's typical of the kinds of
complexities in the dissemination of
American documents during that period
you also write about the Constitution
circulating around Europe being
translated yes back in those days
yes how much of that went on and why did
a great deal there was a great interest
in this and it enters into the thinking
of people working through a foreign
movements all over Europe the book
begins with an argument about American
provincialism the first chapter tries to
explain something we don't often think
about then at the beginning of the
revolution these people were provincials
no one knew of their their importance we
think of them now as Mount Rushmore I
mean these vast figures they weren't
vast figures and their provincialism
their removal from the center of West
the heart of cultured Western Europe was
part of the power that they could
develop in thinking through new ideas
the last chapter which kind of wraps
this up in a way the last chapter shows
the way in which these provincial ideas
become cosmopolitan and circulate
through so much not only of England
where it would naturally circulate but
France as well into Switzerland into
Latin America and the the way these
ideas played out in complex ways all
throughout the Atlantic world and it
seems to me that one of the big stories
and this is the way these provincial
efforts then succeed locally and then
radiates out into the whole of of the
Atlantic world I was reading in your
book faces of revolution when did this
come out my way that came out first I
forgotten now maybe I can look in there
yeah how many books have you read
written well let me just see if I can
get the territory it's 1992 yeah
what I what I was interested in asking
about was Thomas Paine because that's
one of the personalities you write about
this and you say it's one of the most
common sense is one of the most
brilliant pamphlets ever written in
English in the English language and you
went on later to say that that it
written by an enraged man now what role
did this Englishman's well he carried
women Sansa understand that that common
sense was written shortly after he
arrived in America he hadn't been here
for very long what year well it came out
in January 1776 the pamphlet and he had
arrived months before and had undertaken
some kind of history of what was
happening at the time then switched to
this document but he carried with him
the attitudes of someone of a kind of
marginal situation in England very much
in in an enraged state of mind about the
establishment carried over into this
situation in what is really brilliant
prose it is it is a point of view which
many Americans like John Adams loathed
because of the arguments and in which
they they simply both unconstitutional
and social reasons disagreed with but
the prose is brilliant and the metaphors
carry a great deal of force and this
little wonder that this pamphlet
circulated in tens of thousands of
copies in 1776 I don't think it's right
to say that it really precipitated the
revolution but it did give a kind of
rationale for fresh thinking on
dependence and independence that we
hadn't had before you also write this
you say Paine was an ignoramus both in
ideas and in the practice of politics
next to Adams Jefferson Madison or
Wilson and ignorant James Wilson yes oh
I know but I mean yeah but an ignoramus
well he didn't have the sophistication
and learning of these other people who
were really remarkably learning one
thing why did anybody pay attention to
him well because it is a brilliant
pamphlet and because it it served the
cause that they were working for some of
them anyway to think through the
situation of dependence and independence
and whether they should move towards
independence they had after all
organized an army the year before they
had invaded Canada unsuccessfully in the
year before that but they had not
declared independence
they're already moving in that way a
year before they had already organized
themselves into a quasi independent
country but it hadn't happened and
therefore the issue was whether they
would go forward and this pamphlet which
swept through these colonies made a
great deal of difference and the way
people thought I don't think it
determined the outcome but it was
written in such a way as to compel
attention yeah now I know this is maybe
a silly game but I know you you talked
about the the the originalist the people
that believe that today that everything
has written the Constitution ought to be
adhered to fundamentally but what if you
brought back all these characters you
write about and they were sitting around
in this room here looking at what
happened to this country based on what
they wrote back then well would their
reaction be it's impossible to know the
circumstances are so different would
they be happy about the superpower thing
that we have now well some things they
would be happy about some things they
wouldn't but first of all their world
was different it was a completely
different world in social and economic
terms they would have to adjust to this
the great differences here but at a high
level of abstraction I think they would
have considered the operations of the
national government with which they were
so involved successful I think they
would have thought despite the fact that
we have a party system they never
dreamed of they were in fact against
parties even Jefferson will organized
one but our party system is necessary to
the way the Constitution works I think
on the whole they would be pleased with
the way they the national government has
worked even in its tensions and
difficulties through the years but on
more specific issues that relate to the
kind of social world we live in I don't
think there's any way of knowing how
they would have how they would have
thought what about the you know the
cyclical nature of of how much of what
they wrote in our Constitution and the
Federalist Papers came from Europe and
how much original thinking was was
well nobody else has ever done well a
good deal of both they and this is
another part of what I've written in
this book there is a passage I think
it's on page 23 where a Madison's
statement is just to that point I think
I quote that little paragraph there as
I'm having trouble finding 23 when she
me right not 20 I don't think it's 23
there there is a Madison quote maybe
that I underlined it I want to ask you
about go ahead and make the point all
right I find it yo well what Madison is
saying is that they paid attention to
the great names and the great thoughts
of the past the historical documents
they knew they were familiar with and
the great names like Montesquieu but as
he explains and that that paragraph is
exactly to the point they did not revere
them to the point when they dominated
their thinking and that they the the
fact that they were able to break free
from these dominating ideas was one of
the keys to their success and Madison
was keenly aware of that what's original
about the work that they did there are
as I knew Mairead in there there are a
whole series of basic ideas about public
life which were considered at the time
to be illogical for example that you
could divide sovereignty but nobody
believed you could divide sovereignty
but we do between the states and the
nation and no one believed that that was
possible at the time and and they showed
in ways Madison especially the way in
which this could operate successfully
nobody believed that a free Republican
state could be exist on a large scale it
would just fall to pieces because there
were no controls over it if people were
simply governing themselves again they
showed the way in which this was not so
that you could it could operate
successfully over a large expanse and so
there are a number of these key issues
that they're discussing which are
original the quote that I want to ask
you about was from the Federalist Papers
by James Madison
and you say it's the most famous passage
of the Federalist Papers what what makes
a passage famous that passage comes from
the 10th Federalist paper and it is an
argument about how in a large scale
Republic factions will in effect not
cancel each other out but balance out in
a way and in fact the expansion of size
increases multiplies the number of
factions tension rather than tearing the
place apart will tend to stabilize the
system why it's famous is an interesting
question it was not famous until about
nineteen eight 1913 when it was caught
up there was a book by Arthur Bentley in
1980 on interest group politics the
theory of interest group politics and
this seemed to fit these modern views of
interest group politics then Charles
beard picked it up for the wrong reasons
because he thought it was a kind of
Marxist interpretation which it isn't
and so in the 20th century it became
very famous it was not famous in
Madison's own time in fact there's a
very interesting essay written by Larry
Kramer a lawyer at and what you showing
that no one at the time really know
anything about this famous tenth
Federalist paper and nobody paid any
attention to it in the twentieth century
it's become very famous because of the
way it fits into our views of interest
group politics as a balancing core of
the political system this was not quite
what Madison was talking about he was
dealing with the problem that they were
faced with whether you could have a
large scale free Republican state let me
read the passage James Madison wrote and
you take in a greater variety of parties
and interests you make it less probable
that a majority of the whole will have a
common motive to invade the rights of
other citizens or if such a common
motive exists it will be more difficult
for all who feel it to discover their
own strength and to act in unison with
each other see that goes to the heart of
one of the things that mainly concern
Madison and on which I
on the whole he thought he had failed
maybe the protection of minority
interests he was on the one hand a
majoritarian of course that majority in
a free republic should rule on the other
hand so should the interests of
minorities be protected and the problem
he struggled with is how do you do both
and he tried in the Philadelphia
Convention he tried to introduce the
idea of a congressional veto over state
laws which was defeated he tried again
at different stages of his career he
tried different devices to find a way to
control what the states were doing in
what he considered to be oppression of
minorities and it was only really in the
until we got to the 14th amendment that
that power became possible for the
federal government to supervise to some
degree what was happening in the States
he considered this a failure on his part
that he was never able to organize in a
way that would prevent a majority which
of course he believed should dominate
from oppressing the rights of minorities
what do you say when you hear people
today and we hear a lot on our conchos
calling up and saying this is a bad
country that justice isn't taking care
of very well in this country and that
you know all the criticisms about the
people it's a country that only the rich
do well and they go of course into the
slavery and the minorities in this
country upset the way they're treated
what do you say to them thank you I
haven't to agree with much of that I
mean there's this is no perfect country
but but the question is do we have the
capacity to do anything about it and
does the system allow it and it seems to
me that it does
I think these criticisms in many cases
are right that we have this is no
perfect system and no perfect society
and the question is whether and this
throws back in a way to the 18th century
whether the system we live in is capable
of reform in this way in these matters
and I think I think the answer is yes
anybody else in the world live
I not not for an economic standpoint but
that it's a fairer system well I don't
know about what's going a little words
but I mean what you know when you look
around the world and when you know the
people I'm sure you don't you have a lot
of international Senora yes yes well I
think they're quite what you mean the
the English have have a system that's
free to in a different way and they have
a constitutional system that also allows
for reform within it but it's different
from ours
well maybe ask it this way what's your
reaction when you hear an American
politician stand up and say we live in
the greatest country in the world
we're greatest system in the world I
have to think that there's there's
something in that but I don't I don't
want to work out some kind of comparison
rating system but there are other free
countries and there are other countries
in which the capacity for change and
improvement are permanent which we have
and I just don't see any way in which
you can say that we're exclusive in this
but I do think it is a very if I may say
a very great country what about the
checks and balances in this country
versus others you know well I think our
system really does have sometimes it can
become paralytic of course when when the
system doesn't quite work right but the
design that goes back to the 18th
century the design it seems to me was
well thought through and on the whole
successful but it did need the party
system to bring the parts together and
that was not foreseen and in fact it was
only really until the 1820s 1830s that
once saw the way in which a party system
would would bring this disparate parts
of the Constitution together to make the
system work smoothly and I think on the
whole that has been successful so when
well I mean well I'm gonna ask you about
this before we run out of time yes you
give two pages to this yes I do and this
woman on the right hand side of the
screen is in this portrait 36
years old having already had nine
children yes it's mrs. Ellsworth and
that's Oliver Ellsworth on the on the
left and it is a picture of provincial
couple it's part of the argument that
these people were deeply provincial at
the time Ellsworth was a very successful
lawyer a diplomat he became chief
justice at the Supreme Court he designed
the judiciary act that created the
federal court system he was a very
accomplished and sophisticated man and
he lived in Connecticut and that is
where he lived that's his house through
the window and another part another
picture shows the house in large form
and she is a country gentle woman and
that's the way they were depicted by
Ralph Earle and I think accurately I
think that is the kind of people they
were they were proud self-sufficient
unpretentious and accomplished in their
way and that's a picture next to it of
Roger Sherman which which shows it even
more who was Roger Sharon Roger Sherman
who was came from another Connecticut
man who came from practically nothing as
farmers a shoemaker as a merchant and
who dabbled in law became one of the
significant constitutional thinkers of
the period and nobody could be more
provincial than he in that wonderful
portrait by Ralph Thoreau what I want to
start asking earlier is about your own
career you've won two Pulitzer at least
one what National Book Critics Award
when did you start to know that what you
were writing mattered to others in the
general population that's a hard
question I don't know I know when they
mattered to me when did it matter to you
well when I could see that these things
were coming together right and that it
seemed to me I was saying something that
was interesting to me and that seemed to
be fresh and useful in explaining the
way things developed through this period
when they became important to other
people I could only track in the
responses I had from students and
responses from reviews of the book and
what people said about the books but one
of your big awards was in 1986 was there
was one in 1965 I think was yes earliest
did you change the the audience you were
writing for is you got more popular well
I don't I don't think I changed the
audience but the books are very
different the themes are very different
one the first the one you're referring
to was on the ideological origins of the
Revolution which as I said before I
tried to work out that's that followed
it the ideological origins book was an
attempt to show the thinking of of the
leaders of the revolution and that
little book on the origins of American
politics showed the way in which those
ideas peculiarly related to America the
way in which in the developing political
system in the 18th century those ideas
mattered in ways they never did in
England and that book which came out in
I think 86 was a different thing
altogether it's on demographic history
it's a study of 10,000 people who
migrated from the British Isles to
America in the two or three years just
before the Revolution and an attempt to
track their origins and their destinies
in North America and because of the
records are peculiarly available I was
able to track a great many of these and
this is an attempt to depict the lives
of these migrants in different forms to
do it statistically in narrative form in
visual form and otherwise and the book
really is an attempt to use different
devices of historical study concentrated
on this single migration what year were
you the Jefferson lecture within the
last couple of years the Jefferson
lecture which is in revised form is the
first chapter of that book was in 98 and
what it
mean I know it's the national humanities
lecture who did you speak to well there
was a very large group here in
Washington and I was very pleased to
have the opportunity to work out that
essay that's the first one in the book
with the slides that made the point of
provincialism through through that what
can the chapter in this book and it was
a good opportunity because the
facilities were there for showing these
slides in large form and commenting on
them and interpreting the provincialism
in that way it was a wonderful
opportunity which I enjoyed and you were
a millenium lecture would that be a that
was in the White House mrs. Clinton I
think and the president started a series
of millennium lectures they called it to
celebrate the millennium and the first
of those I gave and there was an
interesting evening in which I presented
some of the ideas that are in in that
book is somewhat different for him on
that occasion to get a sense when you're
out making these talks and the speeches
that the public knows what you're
talking about or I mean what's what's
your reaction to what you see in the
others nothing there's nothing very
esoteric about any of this kind of
history I mean there are parts of
history that would be very strange to
people they would not be able to respond
to there's nothing in this of that
nature
these are open public issues they're
familiar and they deal with with people
of great reputation I don't think
there's anything difficult about
explaining about recognizing what these
issues are so as you look back at all of
this whether it's the common sense by
Thomas Paine the Federalist Papers the
Constitution what of all the things that
happened back in those early years you
think some your favorite your favorite
presentation that's met the most you
think over the years to keeping the
structure together what we are how do
you mean on their part or as you look
back at history yeah when you and I I
mean it's Alpert where's your mouth is
the Constitution the Federalist Papers
the common sense which of those had the
biggest impact
to bring us to where we are today well I
think the the the most permanent
creation of that period since they were
not the revolutionary generation were
not social reformers they didn't set out
to change the structure of society they
did set out to change the structure of
public life and the uses of power and
the most important thing they did I
think is to set that up in permanent
form the most obvious expression of it
is the Constitution but the Constitution
rests on 20 years of thinking about this
and it rests also and the
experimentation of the state
constitutions that were put into effect
from 1776 on through the early 80s they
had a great deal of experience in this
so it isn't just the Federal
Constitution it's that whole effort of
constitutionalism that runs through the
generation this is the book we've been
talking about and others to begin the
world anew by Bernard Bailyn
who is a professor emeritus at Harvard
thank you very much for joining us thank
you